- So if you've made a mistake,
something isn't working,
stop throwing good money
after bad, just move on.
Learn the lesson that
you're supposed to learn
and then apply it.
You can always make mistakes,
but don't make the same mistake twice.
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- She's won more awards
than we can mention.
We'd be here all day.
Welcome Stephanie.
- Thank you.
Can you hear me?
Am I on?
- We can, Steph.
- You are super on.
How are you?
- I'm good.
How are you, Gary?
Thank you, Andrea, for that introduction.
That was pretty spectacular.
It sounds like something
w'd do in the ring.
Am I blushing?
You can see I'm blushing.
- Not yet, but one
thing to make you blush,
as a hardcore WWE fan for my whole life,
as Andrea was doing the intro,
talking about leadership,
a lot of times people,
whether it's Me Too, Black Lives Matter,
they react after the fact,
and then there's leadership that reacts
prior to when they're supposed to,
or when the lights are on.
As Andrea was introing you,
I was smiling because the female
aspect of the WWE universe
is so advanced at this point
and I want you to talk about it.
But what I was thinking
in my mind is like,
that is so true because
when I was growing up,
Wendi Richter and the Fabulous
Moolah got some spotlight,
but there just wasn't that much else.
And to watch what's
transformed in the organization
over the last two decades on this front,
and even the way women were positioned
and things of that nature,
it's just incredible what's happened.
Please elaborate.
- Absolutely.
Well, it really started
with how we started to train and recruit
our female athletes.
We wanted the most elite athletes
from both a male and female standpoint,
and we started training
them the same as the men
and giving them the same opportunities,
the same match time,
which like anything else,
the more reps you have, the
better you're gonna get.
And what happened is at NXT,
which started off as
our developmental brand
and evolved into our third global brand,
the women started really stealing the show
and there were chants
of this is wrestling
and women's wrestling.
- [Gary] I remember.
- So then on Ron's SmackDown,
and this was actually February 2015,
we had a women's tag match,
which lasted all of 30
seconds in a three hour show,
which was unfortunately the norm,
and our audience started a hashtag
called give divas a chance
that trended worldwide for three days
demanding more screen time,
better athleticism, better storylines,
better character
development for our women.
And our chairman and CEO, my father,
who you know well Gary,
responded at the highest level and said,
"We hear you, keep watching,
# givedivasachance."
- Steph, I'm really curious.
We have some really interesting parallels
with growing up in a family business,
just on my own curiosity,
just knowing there's a lot
of different people watching
that are in family businesses,
your dad, such an icon,
your grandfather such an icon,
maybe for the people that
are watching right now,
'cause there's a mix of
entrepreneurs, executives,
there's such a mix on this show,
which kudos to Andrea and the team
for creating this environment,
when did your dad start listening to you?
It's really as simple as that,
like knowing your dad is such a force,
like how did you go navigate that?
Like my dad actually gave me a lot of room
'cause I got in at 14
and really proved myself.
And even when he was
giving me a lot of room,
any room he didn't give me
for something that I wanted
was a frustrating point,
it's family dynamics.
How did that evolve for you
where your voice became
bigger at the table?
How was that process for you?
Because I think within that story,
and obviously so many
people know the two of you,
it might help somebody who's
going through it right now,
where they just can't get their parent
to give them that look.
- I think I'm still fighting
for it, honestly, Gary.
It's not like I have a
bigger voice at the table,
that's for sure.
- But I would assume, Steph,
and I'm sorry to interrupt,
it's probably bigger than it
was five or seven years ago.
To your point, like my dad
still also in all my accolades
pushes against some of my ideas.
I respect that, I understand that,
but I would assume it
is a little bit bigger
than it used to be, no?
- Yeah, for sure
and I think it ebbs and
flows and it's complicated.
Family businesses is super complicated,
especially when you have
such a strong personality.
As you were mentioning before
in your own business with you as the boss,
when your boss has such
a strong personality
and is such an icon,
my dad grew up in a trailer park
and he truly lived the American dream
and took what was in Northeast
regional territorial business
and turned it into this global phenomenon
in 108 countries and 28 languages.
We have the WWE Network,
one of the first to launch an OTT service
behind Netflix and Hulu
because he took a calculated risk
betting on himself and his business,
fourth most viewed YouTube
channel in the world,
over a billion social media followers,
that's because of him and his vision.
And it takes someone strong
who makes quick decisions,
to harken back to your
previous conversation,
and who's just truly driven,
but who also listens.
- 100%.
I'm sorry to interrupt,
but I just want to,
I think praise is always
fun when you get to hear it,
literally, because I
realized somewhere in my 30's
that I had the knack of
understanding where attention was,
there are very few people
in the history of business
that understood attention
better than your father.
Whether it was Saturday morning,
whether it was cartoons,
whether it was Saturday
night's main event,
whether it was MTV,
whether it was Cindy Lauper or Liberace,
it's so intuitive to me,
it's how I built my universe,
like I would argue that your father
as an executive from afar
analyzing almost everybody
is one of the great listeners,
even though when he talks,
he talks with conviction and
I'm sure very much juice,
again, knowing family businesses,
but it's funny you said that,
I actually put your dad's listening skills
at the height of modern culture.
- Agreed.
And he doesn't just listen to,
he listens to fans,
he listens to the live audience,
he listens on social media,
but he also listens to our employees.
And he's always said,
you never know where a great
idea is gonna come from.
So he solicits that opinion.
He talks to people, he really does.
- Speaking of leadership,
do you feel that your father,
do you feel you,
do you feel that your husband,
are good at admitting they're wrong?
I've been thinking a lot about listeners,
listeners actually stunningly
don't mind being wrong.
How does that play out
in your leadership style
or the other leaders?
- So for me personally,
I am very transparent and I own mistakes
and I think that that's really important.
I think that,
there's a difference between being wrong
and making mistakes.
And I know that that's
a subtlety in semantics,
but I do think human
psychology plays into that.
And again, just going back to Vince,
he believes in sunk cost.
So if you've made a mistake,
something isn't working,
stop throwing good money after bad,
just move on.
Learn the lesson that
you're supposed to learn
and then apply it.
You can always make mistakes,
but don't make the same mistake twice.
- Steph on that, please.
- [Steph] Never tolerated.
- Actually now, Andrea,
I'm getting extremely selfish here,
everybody's who's watching, I'm sorry,
I'm just nerding out too much.
Steph, genuinely back to like learning
and watching audience,
let's give somebody a huge shout out.
In your career watching the talent,
who most pleasantly surprised you
from the raw human they were
when they walked in and
started doing undercards
to the superstar they became?
Who are you most impressed with
where you're like, oh my gosh,
I'm so proud of X or Y,
they came here as a
young kid or bushy eyed,
or maybe even came from a different league
and had too much ego,
and then you watched them
adjust and become more humble.
Who really, really as a talent,
did you see listened,
whether it was from your
dad, you, or the audience,
who listened the most in
the last decade or two
that you really were incredible with,
like impressed with?
- I'm not sure they listened to the most.
I mean there's so many stories
I could tell throughout time.
I mean even Stone Cold Steve Austin,
who was the ringmaster
and he was standing at Burton
and he tells this story
of he was watching somebody in the ring
and I'm not sure who it was,
and he looked over it
at Vince and he said,
"Hey, you should really
give that kid a push.
They really got something."
And, you know, my dad
looked back and he said,
"Well, all I can provide
is the opportunity.
The rest is up to him."
And Austin said,
that's when the light
bulb went off for him,
like, oh, this is really about me
and my ability to listen and
my ability to grow my brand.
And I think the talent that we have today
have more of an opportunity
than anybody ever did before
because of social media,
'cause they recognize the opportunity
to build their own brand
and their own voice,
both in and outside of the ring,
'cause the more people
are engaged with you
as a person, as an individual,
which again, I think is an evolution,
the more they're gonna
want to see you perform,
or they're gonna want to hear you talk
or see you in the ring.
But I also think, Becky Lynch is a huge,
I could name so many, Drew McIntyre.
I mean, he was here and then he left.
He has truly learned so much
and matured as an individual
to now come back and be champion.
- Let's finish with this.
So many businesses,
big and small pivoting during COVID.
Just watching, again,
'cause I have so much
more knowledge as a fan,
the pivoting that the
organization has done,
what have you learned about this 150 days
about your organization or
about changing your mind
or pivoting or adjusting
or never saying never?
What's the biggest learning point?
Because obviously the way
you're producing today
is so different than ever before.
What's the biggest insight
that you can learn from the macro?
- Well, I think for WWE,
we never went off the air.
So we've continued to produce
seven hours of content
every single week at a minimum
for our television partners,
for USA Network and Fox,
and including our pay-per-views.
WrestleMania went from being
at Raymond James Stadium
and what was supposed to be
in front of 80,000 people
to being performed in
our performance center,
which is essentially a warehouse.
And we took it to two days over one
with absolutely no fans in the audience.
I think the ability to be fluid,
the ability to make changes quickly,
the ability to listen and
then sticking to your mission
and reimagining your business,
but staying true to what your mission is.
And WWE's mission is to put
smiles on people's faces
the world over.
It's something that we
take very seriously.
We've considered a responsibility
to stay on the air to entertain our fans
in the safest way possible,
as long as we can be safe
for our crew, employees and performers.
- I love that.
Steph, just another fun question.
How about you as a human,
between either e-commerce or
your own media consumption,
I think all of us,
our behavior has changed during this time.
Is there any product you now
buy online that's delivered
that you never considered pre COVID
and you're in love with the experience
or is there some show on Netflix or Hulu
or some app that you're playing with,
just you, the human being,
what's a new behavior,
a consumer behavior,
that you can feel that you've
established during this time?
- I've definitely transitioned
more to digital consumption.
I think that you can
look at all of the trends
and everyone always assumed
it was going to go that way,
but I think it's pivoted
three to five times faster
than would have happened without COVID.
And I'm certainly a
part of that transition.
When I do watch programming
on linear television now,
I'm like, ugh, commercials,
like where did they come from?
And that's not to say anything
against our advertising partners.
I think it's going to
force the ad industry
really to partner with content
creators in a different way
to bring an experience
to the viewers or watchers
or fans or consumers,
whatever it is,
that is additive to them
versus taking away the
time of their viewing.
It's gonna cause us all
to be more creative.
- I agree.
I appreciate your time.
I hope you have a
wonderful rest of the year
and I can't wait to see you soon.
- Thank you, Gary.
I can't wait to see you too.
And Andrea, I called
you Andrea, it's Andrea.
- She answers to all
of them, all versions.
She's great like that.
- I'm from the Midwest,
so it's really Andrea, Stephanie.
- Okay, okay.
But one last thing, Gary,
back on the women's evolution,
it ultimately wound up
with our women headlining and
main eventing WrestleMania,
which is akin to our Super
Bowl or the World Cup
and also having not one
but two women's matches
in Saudi Arabia over the past two years.
So I think that's pretty strong.
- Good for you.
Thank you so much.
Hey, everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so
much, so humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.